[Music]
we've summarized I think quite nicely so
far that the internet definitely gives
us all strong views I don't think
anybody here is a neutral opinion on the
Internet
sometimes the force for good sometimes
the force are some pretty terrible
behaviors and then we haven't really
figured out how to solve it yet the four
to five of us now would love to hear
from all of you provoke us with your
questions we'll do our best to answer
them so how do we reach the point on
this where we should nationalize as such
the Internet companies so that they are
accountable my second question is a
question of what the panel think about
individual control I'm a teacher in you
know to 1816 having a smartphone there's
really no need for it and my third
question is on the question of control
because I think that's very important
what do you think about individual
control not just blocking horribly come
on Twitter but how will you control the
internet again I just want you to ask a
jam Jana
yeah just for publication on the point
that you are making around suicide
because actually in the UK I'm able to
in scientists all over the states they
eat since 1981 and to be most
it fell from 1981 to 2007 and it's been
consistent from 2007 through to 2017 so
by that logic you can actually make a
case for the internet having prevented
suicide actually not just say it's just
not no impact on suicide rate I'm
actually just to confirm yeah I'm
reading out from the website of the
Office for National Statistics
I think people would like to challenge
what I'm saying I do why don't you say
you're an spiked and you've gotten this
far ever absolutely doing this forever
can I just I need I need listen being a
macroeconomist about I cannot get
specific what age group are we talking
about is that suicide in general exactly
I'm talking about young people being a
bullet on the internet I don't know
enough about England I know what's
happened in the u.s. in Sweden and many
other countries thank you very much for
your question sorry just let me sure we
just want let's just reduce the Britain
is just gonna get one
one more question then we're gonna take
all of them and we're obviously going to
observe our highest standards of table
manners in this room
[Music]
thank you so that's a great provocative
question let's start with the first one
let's focus on the kids and then build
out so number one do kids under the age
of 16 need a smartphone views on the
panel just yes or no no yes let's do
so yes under parental supervision no for
the other three I say maybe I don't want
to I don't like telling people what to
do with their kids I think that's
between the parent and the canines
myself ask Bill Gates what his children
are allowed to do the funny thing is
that the tech giant's you know achieves
themselves if you look at their kids
they generally don't have access to our
iPads or to iPhones
they're not on a lot of these sites and
the Chiefs themselves are not on these
sites and I think that should tell us a
lot yeah can I just answer one of the
questions about the internet job as long
as we can no it's just a thing funny in
a bit of information so I heard Nick
Clegg who's now with Facebook addressing
a vast crowd in California in February
and he has become very smooth slick
operator for Facebook and he said we
owned the regulation responsibility has
to be with governments we can't do
anything which made me laugh and cry at
the same time that is grotesquely
self-service yes well we all know that
big tech companies and indeed all big
companies have legal departments and
corporate social responsibility
departments where they love to talk
about all the good work that they're
doing so we know that you're absolutely
right government plays a role in
regulating also the companies can
regulate themselves and then we had this
question as well from the gentleman it's
not just about you know companies and
governments it's also our individual
control and tech companies like to tell
us that we all have the power to set our
privacy settings and to use the
technology or not to forbid the
technology to our children or not so I
would like to go around again I'll whip
with
this way on the panel what do we think
about this question of control so we
know the Internet has good things and
bad is it individual corporate or
government
I don't know but we do need more than
individual control because especially
with kids you know yes we parent as best
as we can but actually kids are so much
smarter about all this new stuff than we
will ever be and they are putting
themselves in danger and I find it
terrifying that we are not addressing in
the number of teenage suicides prompted
by what's going on on the web is a very
serious issue
and I think it's really responsible to
diminish that with a whole lot of
numbers we should care about our young
they are our future and this world we've
entered I don't know how you do it but
something needs to be done Thank You
Nigel the answer is all of the above
we need everybody involved in this it is
as Ella said at the beginning still a
very new technology in the overall
scheme of things we're only new really
now getting to grips with what it is
capable of doing and I think we are
starting to address some of the more
malign aspects of this it's it's not a
great situation I mean one of the things
I do is serve as a commissioner on the
global Commission for the stability of
cyberspace and what we're seeing there
is a worrying deterioration in behaviors
and worrying uptick in cyber risk at you
know amongst all forms of actors there
there is no doubt about that
on the other hand if we look at what's
happening now in the United States and
Congress we're starting to see the
emergence of some young tech-savvy
Congress men and women who are actually
starting to call out the issues are
starting to challenge the bland
assurances of the tech giants and I
think this these are things that have
got to be encouraged thank you very much
you know um
I think that it's very clear that social
media is addictive and it's actually set
up to be sold and with other addictive
systems like gambling we control it
because we know the individual control
gets clicked out of functioning you
cannot make people responsible for
something that they can't control so
from the moment they change the stuff
the early Facebook things where people
were more in control into something that
make us addicted it becomes like you
know much worse than cigarette cocaine
it's gambling therefore we do need
controls we cannot leave it to
individuals unfortunately because I'm
always very much for free you don't have
choice and responsibility of the
individual but not when something is
purposely made addictive great points
hello I have a great belief in
individual control and individual agency
and ability to enact control and not
just by using the tools that are out
there you know that Twitter is a very
flawed platform but one thing it does
have is the ability to block anonymous
and accounts which makes my life a whole
lot nicer and so I so I do that but also
this idea of I mean I can kind of feel
that I suspect to Mary Whitehouse
flowing right won't someone think of the
children
it's and that's not being unsympathetic
about the fact that kids can be exposed
to some pretty awful stuff out there but
I think it gets used as a means to
batter the notion of individual agency
and control and the the kind of
contradiction I have to draw out here is
that often it's people of a certain
amount of power who worry about the
others out there who are addicted to
social media or who are unable to enact
their individual control there's there's
often a lot of us and then that goes on
with these discussions you know
academics and politicians talk about the
fact of us to the fact and that we need
to protect the them out there from their
inability to use the internet properly
you know you know what I'm getting up
there there's a kind of there's and
elitism there that I think
very problematic or maybe it's also you
know even personally experienced if you
stay on Facebook's long enough it it
hits your brain for the instant
gratification so clearly it hits the
dopamine then you actually do how
withdrawal reactions when you stop using
it so it's not from you also them it's
just this is a human mechanism that is
there some people are touch more like
with other addictions some people more
easily get a become alcoholics and
others but it's really a mechanism
biological mechanisms that the tech guys
are using to get us hooked onto it and
that's what has to be looked at and
somehow regulated so this actually is
something to learn I tell you that's not
true this this takes us on to the next
question on the one hand we were asked
if we think we need to nationalize tech
companies and create a sort of public
internet I'm not even sure if we need to
nationalize them we could also just
create a public internet that's an
alternative to what's also out there so
if you want to get on to the addictive
no rules wild west internet you can do
that or you can have a sort of public
one almost like public radio versus
private radio or something that's an
option and then we had this question
about Julian Assange representing a
different type of journalism so we're
we're almost taking things that existed
in analog world and going are they
relevant now do we need to do something
new and Julian Assange of course is
currently facing extradition charges the
United States because he didn't just do
journalism he named people who were in
war zones and is accused by the United
States of putting their lives in
jeopardy which is not something the New
York Times which published the same
information that he did did they
redacted the names to protect the
people's lives so I'm just listing these
are really complex issues really nuanced
responses will be required to the panel
Nigel I'm gonna putting you on the hot
scene on that one so no it's a tough one
well when we do it on nationalization I
just like to say we in Britain
nationalized most of our industry during
the 1950s and it did not go well
it's time for it together time to try to
get similar experiences elsewhere on
Julian Assange you wouldn't expect me to
particularly be particularly sympathetic
to Julian Assange and and I'm not
because it seemed to me that a lot of
the material that
he put into the public domain was not
done with the honest intention of
revealing information that was in the
public interest to reveal a large amount
of that information was actually private
diplomatic correspondence that showed
that the United States State Department
as I know them to be are an extremely
responsible and professional and capable
group of people doing their job and
reporting things that need to be kept
secret because I'm afraid you in life
there are things that do need to be kept
secret
I know of no serious philosopher who has
ever argued that transparency is a moral
good you know name one we you know we
need to be able to maintain some degree
or you know of privacy in in terms of
communications for all sorts of reasons
lawyer-client confidentiality
doctor-patient you know etc jasmine
mentioned this play with the title you
know does my bum look big in this
how many marital relationships would
survive you know the husband saying yes
do your bum does look big in this native
yorkshire where such an observation
would be seen as the epitome of tact and
I feel we've we've drifted ever so
slightly
I'm yes men you were in favor of
nationalizing the internet why because I
think I don't know whether one uses the
word naturalized but I think we need to
have a safer form of what is it can be a
very important very good thing and we
have to think about when the inventor
Tim berners-lee says I regret what I did
we have to think about that and make it
better and safer for our children I have
to tell you one very short story why and
I can't answer the Julian Assange
question because I really don't know
what to think about him so
leave that one but there was a very
interesting terrible case in the United
States Backpage is a classified advert
internet business they were showing
kidnapped children who were being
drugged and then trafficked as sex
slaves in the United States parents
found their children's faces on this
classified website and they had to go
and find them it's the most grotesque
story the owners of the sites are the
judges for three years refused to shut
down the site although this trafficking
was going on and it was only when
Congress I think intervened and they
what was their their defense this is
freedom of speech in a democracy that's
how bad it's become this internet but
maybe we need to have an Internet has
ratings like with films so you have to
check in with your digital ID and do P G
R X etc I'm going to end on that very
provocative note I know we have lots
more questions but there is good news
which is that the speakers are going to
be available afterwards for further
chats we're not done yet thank you very
much to all of our speakers thank you
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas her III TV
you